yeah that's probably the biggest thing I
can't say the next thing because I might
actually do it for the next month oh my
God
[Music]
how insane is it that you went from you
know watching the film to now releasing
your own Transformers movie oh it's
really insane like I remember I was in
college at the time it was my freshman
year me and my roommate was like let's
go watch Transformers and uh yeah mine
was just blown like in terms of seeing
the Autobots For the First Time The
Transformations the slow motion shots we
walked out like that was crazy uh what
they did with Sam with Wiki just
everything the themes were on point so
to be there how many years later is that
now
16 years later it's pretty insane like
now put my own print on it and leave
something behind for the Transformers
Legacy like it's pretty cool no I
watched the movie this morning okay and
like the last 40 minutes was just crazy
to me like there was so much action how
much of that was like
how much of that was like you know based
on your experiences and working like
movies like Creed 2 or how much is that
was like you being a fanboy a lot of it
was me being a Fanboy but what I wanted
to do similar to Creed 2 is like make
sure there's
purpose behind the action so like
whatever action beat though there is a
ton of it in the last 40 minutes of the
movie
um it comes from a place of like the
stakes being like rising up and the
mission getting more complicated so it
wasn't action for the sake of action
like there was still story going on
there was still growth in characters and
that's important to me did it in Creed
too in terms of the fights in the ring
and the same with these action pieces we
get to see people work together we're
working together before uh bad guys that
you want to see live or die
um and things like that so I wanted to
feed all of that so I was a total Fanboy
but a lot of it was just me making sure
that their arcs were there too thank you
was there anything in this movie that
you wanted to add but couldn't I wanted
more Predacons in the film that was a
huge piece for me uh we had a lot of
characters as is so it was really tough
to try to fit into Predacon storyline
um
and yeah that's probably the biggest
thing I can't say the next thing because
I might actually do it for the next
month oh my God
no I feel like Transformers fans have
been having this like little beef this
little debate for like a long time yeah
and I think maybe you can settle it
um
the G1 era or these wars which to you is
more Superior oh G1 era oh really yeah I
would not expect that from you well I
love Beast Wars like I and I got a
chance to see it as a as an older
teenager I would say it was kind of like
no I was about to go in my teenage years
and uh I got to appreciate it like the
storyline's good but I think it just
wouldn't be a beast wars without the G1
and like that storyline and just like
the type of characters created like the
The Nostalgia of the franchise and like
what it did culturally during that time
uh yeah I can't I'm a total die hard
like yeah fingers crossed we get a
sequel yeah who are some of the
characters that you'd like to introduce
from the animate series or bring back
from the previous movies from the
previous movies I'm I'm interested in um
I'm interested in where Megatron is I
think that'll be interesting we didn't
get to see him in bumblebee uh clearly
um I'm just curious what we can do with
them you know um I know where he's
technically yeah in the bay verse but I
feel like where the franchise is now to
revive that and see them in a different
light and our G1 sort of for our G1 fans
out there to see in that kind of form
will be really exciting
um at least for me so to speak so I
think that's one that we haven't seen or
tapped into any such an iconic yeah
feeling yeah like you know he's up there
when you mention villains of any sort of
franchise it's like Megatron's on that
list and I'm just like we're too deep
into some movies now without seeing them
for a while